Wuhan is home to two locations two
different origin Stories the seafood
market and the virus research lab an
animal crossover and a lab leak the
theories have been dueling for the three
years that I've been covering this story
from the very first days in Wuhan one
U.S intelligence agency has changed its
mind it now thinks that covid-19 was the
result of a lab leak it would be nice to
put to bed once and for all because
there are a lot of worried people around
the world then and then only do we learn
from what went wrong if anything went
wrong most scientists agree that the
virus's progenitors came from bats
in the natural or zoonotic scenario the
virus mutates to jump from bats to a
third mammal like a Pangolin perhaps or
maybe directly to humans working and
living close to caves eventually it
mutates enough to lead to an outbreak
there's some crossover between that and
versions of a lab leak scenario a
researcher could become exposed to
infected animals or pathogens during
field work or in the laboratory and the
virus makes its way out from there
different U.S intelligence agencies
believe different things four of them
think the most likely scenario is
natural transmission two don't know
based on the evidence they have and two
believe it came from a lab although not
as part of a weapons program
the kwanan market had a cluster of early
covert cases and had been shut down by
authorities when we first visited the
city in January 2020. in this market
that authorities believe a deadly new
strain of coronavirus emerged but other
early cases had no link to the market
and nor has any testing of the supply
chains turned up supporting evidence
and then in the very same city a
laboratory that had been studying
bat-related coronaviruses one where
concerns over safety had been raised
is extremely unlikely this is an
authoritative scientific conclusion that
experts from both China and the who
reached after visiting the relevant
laboratory in Wuhan in fact the who has
said that lab leak is a credible theory
that requires further investigation and
has asked China for its help
that help has not been forthcoming Tom
Cheshire Sky News